fallout 76 is a game that is worth
playing again
coming from someone who like many
dropped the game a couple days after
release i decided to return and i was
amazed at the amount of quality bethesda
has put back into this game
it's easily worthy of being called a
fallout game again and i couldn't be
more proud
to say that fallout 76 now has actual
human npcs both friendly and hostile
engaging quest content
and tons of bug fixes on release it left
a bad taste in many players mouths and
mind too
it was sad to see a once great franchise
be seen like this but i wanted to give
it one last chance and i'm glad i did
so today i'm here to show you what 76 is
like now
and maybe convince you to also give it
one more chance
so let's get started fallout 76 on
launch and even before its initial
release had received numerous complaints
from fans it still to this day has a 52
on metacritic with a 2.8 user score
among the plethora of complaints the few
that stood out the most were a lack of
polish as the game was riddled with bugs
no npcs making the world feel empty
very little content on launch and the
content that did exist however was
pretty much fetch quests
and of course microtransactions i went
back to some old videos on 76 to see
what the bugs looked like and i forgot
how awful this game used to be
i can say with confidence it's nowhere
near this bad anymore
this game definitely still has bugs but
it's not even close to the ones from
launch
a good example is enemies guns not being
centered properly and not seeing the
lasers from the robots
this happened a lot on release to many
players and to me too during my short
time with the game back then but i don't
recall a single time this happened in my
100 hours on the game recently
as i mentioned earlier just because lots
of bugs were fixed doesn't mean the game
is completely polished bugs still exist
in the game but i'll let you know that
most are really not that bad
most of the glitches i've seen during my
playthrough only happen one time
for an example as i was loading into
white spring resort my screen changed to
a green and purple color scheme this
went away almost immediately after
moving the camera
another bug occurred during the
encrypted event the team i was with was
not really equipped to fight this boss
and we got stomped pretty hard the more
you die in the public events the longer
the respawn but after some time i just
couldn't come back i was just sitting
there unable to respawn
the only way i could fix this was
leaving the server and coming back but
of course since i switched servers i
never got the rewards for the quest
the fourth glitch was during the candy
collecting event monster mash without
going too in depth you have to collect
this helmet during the event
something bugged out in my game and i
think it was because i decided to take
the item instead of equip it right then
and there
and that caused the mass to permanently
stay on my character even though it was
showing that it was unequipped on my
pip-boy
apparently this has happened to some
others too and once again leaving and
joining a new server fixes the issue as
it's just a visual glitch on your side
the last of these glitches was during
the foundation questline where i was
told to raise a flag and wave it when i
picked up the flag it duplicated
and i don't necessarily think this is a
bug though more of the repercussions of
a multiplayer game as i think bethesda
did this on purpose
so people weren't waiting one at a time
to wave the flag next up is the more
common bugs and we'll be going in an
ascending order so the later we get into
this section of the video the more this
bug occurred in my game
one i discovered was during the
brotherhood questline and it was the
naked
npc glitch where everyone around me is
in underwear for some reason
as much as i'd love to say this was
intended for the quest knight shin
should be in power armor right now and
that's clearly not the case
this happened a couple times in my
playthrough and of course simply server
hopping fix the issue
one you might be surprised to see this
low however is server crashes
they were insanely frequent on launch
but i only had three throughout my
playthrough
i want to separate the crashes from the
game kind of just freezing as this will
be a little relevant later but the
server only crashed three times for me
one during my first 10 hours and the
other two way later after having put at
least 70 hours in herself i'm not sure
what caused these as it seemed like i
wasn't doing anything crash worthy so
i'm still a little lost
only one of the server crashes was a
major setback which like i said i'll get
into later but the other two were not
terrible at all i'd be in the middle of
fighting people at some location
crash then just go back to the location
spawn point which is probably like 20
feet away so
mere seconds of time were lost the
second most common bug i had is npcs
speaking over themselves dialogue not
starting right away or not being able to
interact with npcs
i group these together as they're all
somewhat related i think the main cause
of this is that i was going too fast
when talking
for example in the game there are daily
quests that come back every day
this quest with the helmlock holes cook
is a prime example you always ask for
radstag meat and tatos
i have tatos at my camp and the near my
monument is always covered with rad
stags
so i always grab these before seeing him
as it saves me a trip
because i already know what he's going
to say i skipped through his dialogue
constantly so he tends to speak
three lines at once this is definitely
my fault since i'm trying to force him
to speed through his dialogue so i'm not
going to count this against bethesda
the other is also technically my fault
too once again another daily is the
photo opportunity with davenport who
asks you to take some pictures with the
two new factions in appalachia being the
settlers and raiders
well he rambles for a long time about
the locale and where to go
personally i don't really care since
i've already heard this before once
you're finished talking with him the
quest should pop up but since i'm
speeding through his dialogue it doesn't
say that i have the quest it's in my pip
boy but the game never told me it was in
there on my screen
this is just a variation of this glitch
as sometimes the quest won't be given at
all for some odd reason devenport
is an odd one out where no matter what
he will always give me the quest
even if i speed through his dialogue
once again kind of my fault since i'm
going too fast skipping through
everything being said
my work around is to let them say a
couple words then skip as to not
overload the game the last one
definitely sucks though and its npc's
not talking to you
the one example that comes to mind was
right at the end of the wastelanders
questline with foundation and crater i
needed this girl rah-rah to climb into
the vent and unlock the door in front of
us the quest even tells me to do so but
for some odd reason when i talk to her
she only says random dialogue unrelated
to the objective
this happened quite a bit and i think
what caused this was that while the npcs
were trying to get into position i was
screwing up their coding or something by
attempting to talk to them early before
they were ready
this happened with chloe at berkeley
springs she has a quest for me too but i
tried talking to her and she wouldn't
interact with me only when i waited and
let her move to the other side of the
street she could then give me the quest
the only fix i found for this is to die
server hop or wait until the npc is
fully done moving to speak with them
it's definitely really annoying but not
a crazy problem overall as i'm used to
it and once again
most of this i caused myself these three
bugs as a group happened probably the
most but individually
not too much it was only really when i
was doing the dailies which of course is
every day but like i said
most of the dailies are the exception to
the quest not popping up glitch for some
reason i wanted to mention this bug
specifically because for some time i
couldn't figure out why
it was happening so i wanted to share
some of my thoughts for those coming
back again
so you aren't confused when this happens
to you probably the most common bug in
the game is
npcs in enemies in walls or frozen in
place
this was honestly still quite uncommon
but just the most common one on this
list if you've played a bethesda game
for
longer than 20 minutes you'll know this
isn't some new discovery bethesda as far
back as skyrim and fallout 3 have had
this issue so i expected it to happen
here although we've gone through all the
bugs i wanted to save this one for last
as it's a really good example when lots
of bugs happen in a short amount of time
during the last mission in the game
you're supposed to launch a nuke from a
missile silo
the last mission is very hard as it
should be you're literally launching a
nuclear weapon
so obviously i died a lot it was a
little infuriating but i wasn't too
bothered due to the circumstances
what bothered me was the amount of
resets that occurred in this short
amount of time
so i was under the impression that
anyone who hops into this mission can do
the mission with me together
this was wrong as someone entered the
silo way later than me and walked right
through the door that i was stuck behind
after i made it through the door i
noticed that the left and right way were
blocked so i figured that this blast
door was supposed to be open
but since the player beat me to the
launch room i couldn't launch my own
missile so i had to restart the entire
mission
after spending 25 minutes or so getting
back to where i was i made it back to
the door but the server crashed as i was
walking around so i had to try it again
for a
third time the third time worked but the
game wasn't done yet i launched the nuke
and started the scorch beast queen fight
lots of people came by and we were doing
fairly well
except during the fight i crashed
thankfully the game has this really cool
feature where you can rejoin your team
if you crashed during an event like this
except the game still had one final nail
to put in my coffin for some odd reason
whether it's a glitch or intended
whenever you leave a server and join a
new one the game takes away your hazmat
suit so when i spawned back i was in the
middle of a literal blast zone
naked and i kept dying i didn't have
enough time to fast travel since i was
over
encumbered and the radiation killed me
too quickly because majority of my
health is radiation
so i left the game and got off for the
night not only did it take me over an
hour to launch the nuke i couldn't even
feel satisfied with my final reward of
defeating the scorch beast queen
while this was easily the worst
experience i've had with the game
something like this has only occurred
one time
where a ton of crashes happened within
an hour or so most of the bugs that i
found were hours or days in between each
other but this one was very different
overall 95 of the game functions like
normal which says a lot considering the
state the game was on launch
if you were someone worried about the
bugs in the game then as a quick summary
fault 76 like any game does have the
occasional bug
and glitch bethesda has done an
excellent job managing the bugs they had
on launch and if you really need proof
go look at some gameplay from day one
then look at the gameplay on screen
it's almost night and day so if you were
one of those people who were turned off
from the severe lack of polish the game
had on launch you have very little to
worry about now
target acquired your camp
vending machines prices are outrageous
the only worst deal i've seen
is the hand you were gelled when
you were born
bethesda fixed most of the bugs so that
the game still has a chance of being
called a game but
also a fallout game but as we know
that's not all it takes to be considered
one
exploration is key to open world games
and especially games like fallout since
its vast and unique world is always
entertaining to explore
within locations you'll find terminal
entries notes and hollow tapes that
explain the stories of these small
places
sometimes the environment itself tells
the story all on its own
the same can be said for fallout 76
during my first couple hours into my
playthrough i came across a mama dulces
and as i was exploring i found a key
card that seemed important and i scoured
the area looking for the entrance until
i found it hidden in the sewers
even in fallout 3 mama dulce has been
used as a base of operations for the
chinese and it's the exact same thing
here
just in the beginning area called the
forest you can find areas like this
there is point pleasant which has ties
to mothman an island inhabited by
deathclaws and even a literal vault
also i think the forest has the most
locations out of the six regions in the
game so lots of your exploration content
will be packed in here
that doesn't mean the other regions
aren't worth it though my two favorite
locations in the game aren't even in the
first area
the garahana state and ash heap and the
monorail elevator in the savage divide
both offer stunning views of appalachia
the elevator can even possibly see the
nukes that go off nearby in cranberry
bog
obviously fallout isn't all about
stunning views so if you want some more
interesting places i highly recommend
west tech as it's excellent for
uncovering more stories about the fev
virus as well as a transmission station
deep in the forest
you'll come to the transmission station
during the brotherhood questline so i
won't spoil too much but it's quite the
interesting place
the beauty of fallout has always been
going to a place without knowing its
history and uncovering it for yourself
so it'd be rude of me to spoil all the
beautiful locations this game has as it
ruins the fun
but do take my word for it as someone
who explores all the locations he can in
any fallout game 76 made me feel right
at home
even though the game is multiplayer that
doesn't take away from the fun of
exploring a new region of the map it
also doesn't take away from the quality
and quantity of locations as well
i don't have a completely accurate
number as there's hundreds of locations
across each game but according to some
sources 76 has more locations than
fallout 4 which had around 325
also with this game being multiplayer
it's updated frequently and almost every
dlc update has introduced more locations
so it's only going to continue to grow
i also think i'm reaching with this
point but i think if you're new to a
location and have never visited before
then the enemies in lube will always
respawn as to not confuse the player
it would be weird to walk up to an area
you didn't know was cleared out
see there's no enemies then come back an
hour later on your next visit to find
them all there so i think at least for
the first visit especially when visiting
indoor areas the game will spawn stuff
no matter what
i'm not 100 sure on this but i do have
strong suspicions that's the case
earlier i mentioned the six regions the
game has six regions easily divided by
the color schemes on the map you have
the forest the toxic valley ash heap
savage divide the meyer and cranberry
bog
i'll explain this point more in the
gameplay section but most of these areas
can be explored right away since most
enemies scale to the player's level but
i highly recommend taking it one area at
a time
for a couple days i explored every
location in the forest then moved to the
next region when i was finished when
entering a new area though
sometimes a new quest may pop up in your
miscellaneous tab for example when going
to west tech you'll receive a marker
saying uncover the secrets of westec
this doesn't happen in every area though
just most of them the quest may just be
as simple as going to a different
section of the building forcing the
player to look for the story themselves
sometimes it leads to a daily quest like
the one with chloe where it says
investigate berkeley springs but
sometimes it's an official side quest
like when entering the mire or bog for
the first time you'll get a distress
call which leads to a long-winded quest
with an astronaut named sophia screw the
exploration is there and it rewards you
for doing so
one big strong point to exploration in
these games is the vaults but for me
76 doesn't really nail that feeling for
me while the exploration and excitement
of uncovering a new area's secrets is
still there
the vault's got the short end of the
stick all of the vaults are either
inaccessible or unlocked through the
completion of something other than vault
76 and 94.
vault 51 is locked behind the nuclear
winter overseer levels so the more you
play the mode the more you uncover but
not everyone likes battle royales and it
was also just released that the game
mode is going to be shutting down in
september so
no one really knows what's going to
happen to the vault like i stated vault
94 can be explored as well as 76 without
any requirements vault 96 and 63 however
just won't open
96 is in the daily ops missions but in
adventure mode out of the operations
neither can be open so they just sit
there
dormant this is most likely due to the
vaults being used for some other content
years ago called vault raids but that
content was removed from the game so now
they just exist on the map
the last is 79 which is tied to the
wastelanders questline between the
raiders and settlers which while it does
take a long time to finish the vault and
story it was very entertaining while
this game's vault
accessibility and story are fairly okay
it's leagues behind the pass games where
you could simply just walk into any
vault and it was all accessible to you
like i said it got the short end of the
stick sadly
fallout to me is a combination of a few
things it's got a post-apocalyptic
setting
mysterious locations captivating story
and unique gameplay
so far in the video we've proved that 76
has nailed the first two so
let's talk about the last two bullet
points fallout 76 is different in the
way it handles
its gameplay this isn't a single player
game it has to be tuned around
multiplayer which means an
end game various options and methods of
farming loot viable builds and giving
the player enough to do
76 can seem very intimidating at lower
levels since enemies hit harder than it
may
seem causing you to die quite a bit but
the gun play is fun and simple your
go-to shooting will still be with the
help of vats and surprisingly for a
multiplayer game it's very effective
it's originally a dumbed down version of
it
only allowing you to select the whole
body but you can then get a perk that
goes back to that normal selective body
part style of vats
originally i thought this was a waste of
time having to constantly move to the
appropriate body part while being shot
at but it's incredibly helpful
critical hits also return from fallout 4
and they act the same they do a good
chunk of damage and always hit even if
the chance is super low
to shoot or hit things you're gonna need
weapons armor weapons power armor and
chemistry workbenches also return
but are a little different from fallout
4. in fallout 4 the player needed the
appropriate perk level and the gun they
wanted to mod to add attachments
gun nut allowed you to add mods to the
gun so increasing that was the way to go
this is the same thing for 76 except not
everything is available to you you not
only need the plans for the gun but also
the mods as well
that's where the grind comes in and it's
actually balanced for both heavy and
light weapons plans are either specific
rewards from side quests like the combat
rifle or if it's not predetermined then
you'll have to farm events in dailies or
just buy them
mods are the same way but you can
dismantle the guns themselves to have a
better chance of getting a mod
see the combat rifle has dozens of mods
you can unlock but heavy guns like the
minigun may have
6 or 8 mods so you would think go with
the bigger weapons because they have
less mods to find but you have to
remember that finding a minigun
first is a lot harder than a combat
rifle most guns with lots of attachments
can be found easily on enemies whereas
bigger guns with less mods aren't as
common
of course there are some exceptions a
popular weapon amongst the super mutants
is a board but the board only has three
mods so not everything is like this but
most
guns tend to follow this dynamic and all
weapons are
fairly acceptable to a degree thanks to
the plethora of damage perks and the
fact that enemies are now scaled to your
rank and not the area anymore you can
pretty much use any weapon and it will
still be affected originally the white
spring resort had some high level ghouls
that patrolled the area but now they're
scaled to your level
not some preset number which is very
helpful for those who need to go across
the map for a quest
after some time you should be able to
rank up and 76 also does this
differently than the previous entries
firstly everyone starts with one in
every special stat every level from 1 to
50 you can add a special point to add to
your stats
and the new max number is 15 as opposed
to 10. you can do some interesting
combinations with this but it will have
some drawbacks on my current build my
luck and agility is at 15 but i have to
sacrifice my strength for it during
these levels you will also get perks and
every 5 levels you'll also get a perk
pack filled with some extra cards so the
level up process
is picking a special stat and then a
card but you don't have to choose the
same stat by default if you select
strength the game gives you a list of
strength perks but you don't have to
pick them you could put points into
strength but
choose an agility card which is
extremely helpful and you can only put
in as many numbers as the special stat
has
so since i have a 2 in strength my only
options are 2 level 1 cards or 1 level 2
card my luck however can be used freely
since i have 15 points to play around
with to rank up your card it's as simple
as getting two of the same card and then
combining it
if you want to get to tier 3 just add
one more and don't worry if you don't
know what build or play style to use
since the game just added a punch card
machine in the current season locked and
loaded
allowing you to customize your special
points whenever you want and have
presets so you don't need to remember
all of it
as surprising as it sounds respecting
your stats was not in the game until a
couple months ago so this is a perfect
time for new players to join
to add to this even past level 50 you
can still get perk cards so you don't
need to worry about the build right away
due to me going back and forth between
ideas i didn't finish my build at level
50 like you would expect i finished it
at level 68
and now since i'm a much higher level
i'm using that extra slot and the punch
card to make another build giving me
more reasons to play
the biggest reason that perk cards are
still available after level 50 is
because you now have access to legendary
perks these can only be chosen at
specific level
milestones 50 75 100 150
etc and to level them up you need to use
perk coins which has gotten by scrapping
the cards you don't want these perks are
incredibly helpful
one can completely bypass all terminals
and locks up to a specific
level or you can buy one that increases
one of your special stats unrelated to
the current stats you have
so going back to my example i can't
change what i have i'm stuck with two
strengths but with that legendary perk
card i can raise my strength without
sacrificing other stats all
these culminate into builds and
playstyles i discussed before there's a
lot of leeway in this game pretty much
any gun can work at an above average
level especially with the
large amount of additional legendary
effects the game has but it's not as
simple as that as most players have
commented that there are very few
top builds in the game yes a shotgun or
gunslinger can work but there's tons of
other builds just
simply better than them you may have
noticed in the gameplay 90 of my health
bar is gone
this is to help with a legendary effect
called bloodied the less health you have
the more damage you do
and since my build is built around
sneaking i'm getting incredible base
damage on top of the sneak attack damage
it's not as foolproof as it may seem as
it does have lots of weaknesses like the
ability to get melted in the blink of an
eye but with a change of perks you could
put on some power armor and be almost
invincible once again this isn't the
only build available the game has tons
of viable builds but there's not a lot
of top tier builds but bloodied isn't
the only way to go
i've seen people use melee weapons at
full health holding their own against
the toughest boss in the game so it's
definitely possible but don't be
surprised if you join a team and almost
everybody has red health bars
i can't comment too much on this as i
haven't had nearly enough experience to
experiment with every build and weapon
but it does seem to be the general
consensus in the community that there is
very few
top builds in the game but there are
quite a few viable builds that can work
at an above average level the biggest
problem i can already see growing
is the end game simply put most players
agree to some extent the end game in
fallout 76 is
lacking currently for me i still have
lots of stuff to finish so even 100
hours later i'm content with what i'm
doing but for players who've been
playing for years it might not be that
way the end game is a combination of a
few things
keeping up with the daily quests and the
daily ops exchanging legendaries for
script
to get better chances at better
legendaries and exchanging treasury
notes for gold to get unique plans
and overall just min-maxing the
character the other item on the
checklist is farming the bosses as they
drop a few plans and some rare materials
except there are only two bosses in the
game and one is farmed way more than the
other so you could really only say
it's just the queen recently though
there was news about expeditions coming
into the game starting with the pit from
fallout 3 so maybe there will be bosses
in there which would definitely amplify
the end game tremendously the last part
of the gameplay section would be pvp
since this is a multiplayer game after
all but if i'm being honest
i don't really have much to say besides
nuclear winter which is all around pvp
i've never gotten into a shootout with
another player one person i saw on
reddit summed up this phenomenon quite
well
when bethesda marketed fallout 76 they
said it was a fallout game with pvp
but the community saw it as fallout with
co-op most players are super nice and
helpful
without speaking a word i've completed
tons of daily ops and boss fights with
no one communicating
there's numerous stories on reddit that
talk about people dropping their weapons
by accident and some players have
grabbed the guns off the ground but it
was only so that other players didn't
steal it from the original player even
in my experience when i was around level
10 within a couple hours of each other
two level 300 players gave me 1 000
rounds of ammo and a very powerful level
10 pipe gun this helped me clear that
early game power struggle i talked about
earlier now of course not everyone will
have this experience so don't be
expecting handouts but a lot of people
are super friendly in this game and
willing to help on others which is why
i've never been in a shootout with
another person i even tried to start a
couple fights myself but with the way
pvp works if you shoot at someone it
does
almost zero damage unless they shoot
back so it's a complete waste of ammo so
if you were someone who wanted to play
this game to start fights with random
players
it's probably not going to happen
overall 76 is combat and gameplay is fun
and it will keep you entertained for a
while there's enough content in dailies
to do
on top of the quests locations and
material farming that you'll probably
have too much to do rather than not
enough at least for a while
currently at level 120 with nearly 100
hours in i still have side quests to
finish
a completely new build i want to create
regions to fully explore and tons of
building in my camp to do so i'll be
entertained for
many more hours so the gameplay in
combat is captivating and engaging
the locations and atmosphere immerse you
in the world making you want to explore
all the areas the game has to offer the
only thing we haven't discussed yet is
the story
i know y'all weren't gonna start this
party without me
ain't that right 7-6
who are you my name's meg i run the
crater
and this is my crew so for me while the
main story lacks of it i think it's
absolutely carried by the other main
quests added in the later dlcs
of course spoiler warning ahead if you
don't want to hear any of this so the
main premise of 76
is that you leave the vault in search of
the overseer you encounter a camper
verse that has a hollow tape and then
this points you to flatwoods
throughout the main story you'll work
and join various factions throughout
appalachia some are new factions like
the responders and free states but some
are more recognizable like the enclave
and the brotherhood of steel
you do have to remember though this is
the game's main story so this is when no
human npcs were introduced so don't
expect to find anything it's mostly just
hollow tapes and robots the beginning
section with the responders is mostly
about teaching you the basics of the
game like cooking and scavenging and
while learning the basics you'll also
learn a bit more about that scorched
plague and ways to stop it you'll then
go through various factions like
previously stated and will end a new
meeting with the enclave in seizing
control of a missile silo and using that
missile silo to destroy the scorched
most of it to be honest
felt like a drag to play through until
the enclave was introduced as things
started to pick up speed but overall it
wasn't terrible it didn't help that
there were no human npcs to feel
connected to it just felt like a string
of side quests until you met modis one
of the few characters in the story with
actual personality you could argue that
rose has some charm too
and you'd be correct if anything i find
that she's more enjoyable to talk to
than modis but her quests were just not
engaging at all
all of them felt like fetch quests and
were just not memorable the enclave have
always felt secretive and classified so
when modis was very open to discussing
the enclave i was all ears
it's not a terrible questline by any
means it's definitely nowhere as good as
the pass game's main story but like i
said i think the dlcs more than make up
for it wastelanders and steel dawn
introduced two new storylines taking
place a year after the main story
raiders settlers and the brotherhood of
steel have moved into appalachia the
raiders and settlers questline is fun
allowing you to do actual missions with
the raiders it's highly recommended
though that you do beat the main story
as a couple things may sound a bit
confusing
for example the first thing you do with
each faction is to convince them to get
inoculated so that more scorched are
created within appalachias like i said
that was the whole point of the main
story
you yourself get inoculated very early
on in the game so if you do this quest
line first you may be a bit confused on
what they're talking about
eventually you'll discover that nearby
vault 79 has the country's gold reserves
inside which as the overseer explains
could be used to start a brand new
currency and economy problem is the
security is extremely tough so you need
the help of one of the factions to break
inside the main quest showcases lots of
ideals and beliefs from both factions
the raiders of crater led by meg are a
conglomerate of five smaller raider
groups all of whom are different from
one another
so those ideals they carry with them
tend to clash a bit the settlers of
foundation are a large group of people
that are just looking to survive the
wasteland so they are a lot more
friendlier than the raiders as long as
you're not an outsider i really liked
this questline and the rewards are
excellent as a new currency gold boolean
was introduced allowing you to unlock
exclusive outfits and power armor the
only negative i have is something that's
consistent across the game and that's
decision making bethesda doesn't give
your actions consequences i was under
the impression that whoever i chose will
like me and the others will hate me but
that's not the case
both factions are very much alive and
prospering and they don't really care
about my decision
in my playthrough i went with the
raiders but i split some of the gold
with foundation clearly that wasn't the
deal that me and meg decided on so i
betrayed her trust
she said that that gold the goal that
was rightfully theirs now has to be
stolen back which means i just made
their jobs a whole lot harder
meg should despise me for going behind
her back like this but i can still walk
around crater just fine without any
issue in fact not even
the raiders bring this interaction up
only meg mentions it one time
now i do understand why they possibly
did this once you hit certain tiers of
reputation you get more rewards and
bethesda probably wanted all players to
get all the rewards which i commend them
for but then what's the point of
choosing if there's no consequences
i literally betrayed an entire faction
and they still accept me as one of their
own it just doesn't make sense to me the
last dlc
is with the brotherhood of steel during
the steel dawn dlc and they're led by a
paladin ramani
under her is knight shin and scribe
valdez people who you will get to know
throughout the story
both romani and shin also have
conflicting ideals
shins vary by the book wanting to
maintain the structured order of command
no matter what but romani doesn't want
that she wants to be free of the elder's
constant reign over them these two clash
constantly throughout the later parts of
the story and with the upcoming part 2
dlc
steel rain it may drive them to kill
each other personally i'm extremely
excited for this to continue as i really
like the steel dawn questline and from
the looks of the trailer we might
actually get some consequences
now there are a million ways for
bethesda to not do that but i'm hoping
that we can actually get to kill one of
them and live with our decision
this type of decision making is
something that's drastically missing
from this game
and i'm hoping steel rain brings it back
both wastelanders and steel dawn are
excellent additions to the game by not
only adding new content in the form of
quests but also accompanying those
quests with engaging stories and
conflicts that make you want to continue
playing doing these quests felt great
as it felt like a proper fallout game
again i was so engaged in the storyline
of the brotherhood of steel that i ran
through it in one sitting and i haven't
done that in a very long time
the last and arguably the most important
part of this video is the micro
transactions fallout has a shop
accessible from the main menu called the
atomic shop
using the atom currency you can buy
items from this shop
the positives to the shop is every day
there's a free item that while not
always great is nice to stockpile
something helpful especially for newer
players is that by checking the
challenges menu you can see some easy
ways to get atoms i currently have close
to 3 000 atoms thanks to these
challenges and
side note i didn't even go out of my way
to get these done i just played the game
like normal and a bunch of them unlocked
i personally don't have an issue with
the atomic shop but this is only because
i've purchased things from my camp
arguably the most important purchases
from this menu and i'm currently
considering getting a skin for the 50
cal however
some of these items are atrocious at
this exact time in my script it's june
23rd
and two items just came to the shop one
is the display and the other is clothing
except the clothing is the vault-tec
guy's outfit from fallout 4 and the
display case while cool can only show
off the masks from the fashion
seasonal event which hasn't come back in
months 500 to 700 items isn't a large
price but
700 atoms for a suit and 500 for a
display case that is only for one
specific item
is just absurd the other things that
belong in this section are the seasonal
scoreboard and the infamous
fallout first the scoreboard is like a
battle pass and it's not purchasable
every scoreboard is free and i'm okay
with free rewards especially when some
of them are actually pretty cool
i would say my only complaint though is
that the scoreboard does have a large
amount of consumables like
weight boosters and lunchboxes and not a
lot of actual content like skins
outfits or camp related stuff so more of
those would be nice
the last is fallout first and this
actually isn't that bad firstly no one's
gonna kill you anymore for having the
subscription so that worries out of the
way but for those who don't know fallout
first is a subscription that is thirteen
dollars a month or a hundred dollars a
year and this gives you access to a few
things
you're given 1 650 atoms per month which
is actually a cheaper alternative than
just buying the 1
650 items from the store by itself you
also get a scrap box survival 10
access to exclusive cosmetics and
rewards that are in the atomic shop or
the scoreboard and having the ability to
start a private world
honestly and i think a lot of players
can agree with me the most important
part of this subscription is the
scrapbox and the survival tent
the scrapbox was helpful not only to
alleviate the weight in my stash a bit
but also keep things organized and
simple
this is a box with unlimited pounds of
weight only for
junk so for people who want to hoard all
sorts of junk or want to farm large
amounts of a specific material
this is perfect the best part of this is
that most players will buy the
subscription for a month and a good
portion of that month is spent farming
materials usually lead in steel for ammo
they'll cancel the subscription and then
depending on how many materials they got
throughout that month they may not have
to purchase this subscription for
another four months
when the subscription is gone you can
still take and use the junk from the
scrapbox you just can't put any more
junk
in the survival tent is like a home away
from home it has a bed
stash scrap box cooking station and
usually an instrument
the issue with farming materials is that
you'll be over-encumbered very quickly
and instead of walking to the nearest
workbench if there even is one
you can just plop down a tent anywhere
and put all that junk in the scrap box
it's extremely efficient the extra
cosmetics are pretty cool too but that's
more subjective as some may find these
rewards better than others
the last part is private worlds now i
did a lot of research on this i wanted
to do what i mentioned earlier buy
fallout first then farm for a month but
i wanted to make sure those items
respawned
i never mentioned material farming that
much in this video and it probably
belongs in the gameplay section but it's
very relevant here
eventually there will come a point where
you need some material and obviously
you're going to want a lot of it fast
thankfully there's locations and enemies
that can help with this but
in comes the problem of the game being
multiplayer to explain let's show an
example
i need some ammo specifically 45 round
ammo which needs gunpowder steel and
lead i can knock the steel and lead out
of the materials list with some tin
cans thankfully there are four chimes of
tin cans that have nine cans per chime
at the white spring resort so what i do
is i spawn in at the resort
run into the building grab the chimes
and once i'm done i server hop by
leaving the game and joining a new one
except the issue is that there's no way
in two years i'm the only person who's
discovered this
a good 70 of the time the chimes are
gone this is always going to happen and
it's not like i'm picking the get rich
quick scheme either
the best item in the game for the most
lead possible is weights
weight rooms have tons of weights all
with various amounts of lead in them and
that is almost
always taken so i farmed the cans since
it's not the fastest method but it's
definitely not the slowest either
private worlds are also really helpful
with nukes and workshops you can claim
the workshops in your private world then
no one's going to overtake them since
you're alone so you can set up
extractors and extract the resources
that way and later in the game flux can
be very helpful for some crafting
material a good way to find them is to
do specific areas of the game and gather
the flora that spawn there
of course the very last but most obvious
benefit to this is no players will come
and kill you and take your stuff
but personally like i said before my
entire time on the game i've only been
killed one time
so while it's a really cool bonus if
you're buying fallout first with the
number one reason being
so that players can't kill you i think
you're wasting your money
overall fallout first is very much worth
the money you're spending
some people have said that buying this
as a new player is not worth it but once
you get farther into the game and become
a consistent daily player it's
definitely worth the 13
price and i'm inclined to agree an
unlimited stash of scrap the ability to
place a tent wherever i want when i'm
full
are easily the best reasons for buying
the subscription and it's something i
definitely recommend
as much as bethesda wants to forget
about the past everyone's going to
remember fallout 76 as bethesda's worst
blunder this game was an unpolished mess
on launch with very little incentive to
grind but now it's turned into one of my
favorite games of the year
if you were like me someone who wrote
off the game and never returned please
give it one more try and see if you like
the improvements
i've been checking the 76 reddit
frequently since i've started playing
and i've seen dozens of the same posts
of people talking about the same thing i
did
going into the game again not expecting
much but leaving having played one of
the best games in recent years
with that however we've reached the end
of the video if you want to try fallout
76 for yourself
i think it's close to 20 or 30 dollars
but if you are worried about that price
for
xbox and pc owners you can pick up game
pass for five dollars and play it that
way
as always thank you for watching the
video let me know what you think about
the video as well
if you're new make sure to subscribe for
more content like this and if you're a
returning viewer i thank you for coming
back
like always everyone take care and
goodbye
[Music]